Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. No one was like him. Terrible were his crimes. But if you wish to blackguard the great king, think how mean, obscure and dull you are. Your labour's lowly and your merit's less. You talking to me?
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、系列节目的抢先收听，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。没有人像他那样。他的罪行是如此可怕。但如果你想诽谤这位伟大的国王，想一想你是多么卑微、默默无闻且愚钝。你的劳作卑微，你的功绩更少。你在跟我说话吗？
Tom Lysambrook. Yeah, I was going to say that. That's Robert Lowell, his poem on alexander um we've talked about whether well he kind of is though isn't he because i think what he's saying is that alexander is like a he's the apex predator he's a kind of tyrannosaur and that people saying oh you know he did terrible things or he he's a a kind of evil man for conquering the world i mean you might as well blame a tyrannosaur for yes savaging flesh of a Triceratops. Well, it's absurd to blame a king in, you know,
汤姆·莱桑布鲁克。是的，我正要说呢。那是罗伯特·洛厄尔（Robert Lowell）关于亚历山大的诗……我们讨论过亚历山大是否算，嗯，他某种程度上确实是，对吧？因为我认为他所说的意思是，亚历山大就像一个……他是顶级掠食者，他是一种暴龙。人们说“哦，你知道的，他做了可怕的事”或者“他是个邪恶的人，因为他征服了世界”——我的意思是，你还不如去责怪一只暴龙去撕扯三角龙的血肉。好吧，指责一个国王在……
the 4th century BC for trying to conquer other people. I mean, that's kind of the job to switch. Well, having said that, I mean, obviously, there were people who blamed him. So Demosthenes, when the news came that Alexander had died, said, surely the stench of his corpse would fill the world. Demosthenes is a terrible man, though, isn't he? I knew you'd be team Alexander.
公元前4世纪，试图征服其他人，这太荒谬了。我的意思是，这本来就是他的工作。话虽如此，我的意思是，显然也有人指责他。因此，德摩斯梯尼（Demosthenes）听到亚历山大去世的消息时说，他的尸臭一定弥漫了整个世界。不过德摩斯梯尼是个糟糕的人，对吧？我早就知道你会加入亚历山大阵营。
A Ciceronian figure. Yeah, he is. So obviously we're talking Alexander the Great. This is the second part of our series on Alexander. In the first part, Dominic, you leading the way because you've written a top children's book on Alexander. Top, top children's book.. Top, top children's book. A top, top children's book.
一个西塞罗式的人物。是的，他确实是。所以我们显然是在谈论亚历山大大帝。这是我们关于亚历山大系列的第二部分。在第一部分中，多米尼克，你带了头，因为你写了一本关于亚历山大的顶级儿童读物。一本顶级顶级儿童读物……顶级顶级儿童读物。一本顶级顶级儿童读物。
Very good Christmas present, if I can say so. If you don't know what to buy your nephew or something or your niece, this is clearly the thing. But surely you don't need to wait for Christmas. You could buy one for yourself, buy one for your friends, and then buy one for all your relatives at Christmas. Well, I'm assuming that listeners all have a copy already, right? Because it'll have been out for two or three days. So there's no excuse. Well, they haven't had a day to listen to the previous ideal. All have a copy already, right? Because it'll have been out for two or three days. So there's no excuse. Well, they've had a day to listen to the previous podcast.
如果我可以这么说的话，这是一个非常好的圣诞礼物。如果你不知道该给你的侄子还是外甥女买点什么，这显然就是首选。但你肯定不用等到圣诞节吧。你可以给自己买一本，给朋友买一本，然后在圣诞节时给所有的亲戚各买一本。好吧，我假设听众们都已经有一本了，对吧？因为它已经出版两三天了。所以没有任何借口。好吧，他们甚至连一天的时间都没有用来听之前的……所有人都已经有一本了，对吧？因为它已经出版两三天了。所以没有任何借口。好吧，他们有一整天的时间来听之前的播客。
They have. So I'm sure they'll be rushing out. Anyway, so in the previous episode, we got Alexander to Egypt. He's founded Alexandria. He's had an audience with Amun in the oasis of Siwa. And now he is preparing to strike east and attack Darius III, King of Persia. So I think we said in the last episode,
他们确实有。所以我确信他们会抢购一空。无论如何，所以在上一集里，我们讲到亚历山大到了埃及。他建立了亚历山大港。他在锡瓦绿洲觐见了阿蒙神。现在他正准备向东进击，进攻波斯国王大流士三世。所以我想我们在上一集里说过，
didn't we, this was the point at which you could have stopped. I mean, a sensible thing. And in fact, his general Parmenian has said to him, basically, why don't you take the deal
对吧，这就是你本可以停下来的时候。我的意思是，这是一个明智的做法。事实上，他的将军帕曼尼翁（Parmenion）对他说，基本上，你为什么不接受大流士给你的条件呢？
that Darius is offering you, which is you take the western bit of the kingdom, the western thing. And in fact, his general Parmenion has said to him, basically, why don't you take the deal that Darius is offering you? Which is you take the Western bit of the kingdom, the Western fringe of the Persian empire. You're suddenly by far the richest man probably who's ever been in Greece. Why don't you take the deal? And Alexander says- But if you're mean, obscure and dull,
大流士提供的条件是：你占领王国的西部，即波斯帝国的西部边缘。你突然之间成了希腊有史以来最富有的人。你为什么不接受这个条件呢？亚历山大说——但如果你卑微、默默无闻又愚钝，
that's what you do. But if you're not, if you're Alexander, you go, let's go. Let's go. And so he does. He and his school friends and these other blokes who followed them, they set off from Memphis.
你才会那样做。但如果你不是，如果你是亚历山大，你会说：我们走。我们走。于是他就这么做了。他、他的同窗好友以及其他追随他们的家伙们，从孟菲斯出发了。
They go back up the coast of Phoenicia, and then they turn right. So they turn east. Now, Darius all this time has been amassing a new army, hasn't he? In Babylon, I think it is. He's got elephants. He's got more of his own family. And he's got chariots with sides. Yeah.
他们沿着腓尼基海岸北上，然后向右转。也就是向东转。现在，大流士一直在集结新军队，对吧？我想是在巴比伦。他有大象，有更多的王室成员，还有带侧板的战车。是的。
So he's got some distant cousin called Bessus. Bessus is a very bad man. He's a more of his own family. And he's got chariots with sides. Yeah. So he's got some distant cousin called Bessus. Bessus is a very bad man. He's a very bad... He's... Yeah, he's basically a sort of... Like a sort of Hollywood casting agency from the 1950s has been asked to supply a Persian. Bessus is the man they supply.
所以他有一个远亲叫贝苏斯（Bessus）。贝苏斯是个非常坏的人。他有更多的王室成员，还有带侧板的战车。是的。所以他有一个远亲叫贝苏斯。贝苏斯是个非常坏的人。他是个非常坏的……他……是的，他基本上有点像……就像20世纪50年代的好莱坞选角公司被要求提供一个波斯人时，贝苏斯就是他们提供的人选。
He's sort of black-bearded, dark-eyed... Twirling a moustache. Twirling a moustache, exactlying a moustache exactly he's a pantomime villain he's come from bactria with all this cavalry from bactria so bactria is bactria and sogdiana it's afghanistan and beyond yeah exactly it's sort of the fringes of iran turkmenistan afghanistan it's this kind of heartland of cavalry and horsemen and he's pitched up with all these sort of wild warriors and um derise has what seems a very good plan he's going to tempt alexander he's going to burn all the fields um and he's going to tempt alexander has to keep coming um scorched earth policy basically and he's decided where he wants to face him he wants to face him into players called place called galga
他有点黑胡子、黑眼睛……捻着胡子。捻着胡子，确切地说，捻着胡子，他就是一个滑稽剧里的反派。他带着巴克特里亚的所有骑兵从巴克特里亚赶来——所以巴克特里亚就是巴克特里亚和粟特，也就是阿富汗及更远的地方。是的，没错，这有点像是伊朗、土库曼斯坦和阿富汗的边缘地带，这里是骑兵和骑马者的核心地带。他带着这群野蛮的战士赶来，而且……大流士有一个看似非常好的计划：他要诱敌深入亚历山大，他要烧毁所有的田地，他要诱使亚历山大不得不继续前进——基本上就是焦土政策。而且他已经选定了他想跟亚历山大交战的地方，他想在一个叫高加米拉的地方跟亚历山大决战。
mila which i've been to have you i was going to askamela. Which I've been to. Have you? I was going to ask you, because I know you've been to kind of Iraq and Kurdistan. Yeah, so Gaugamela is also called Arbella. Yeah. Arbella is current day Erbil. I think it's about 30 miles south of where the battle was fought. So it's Kurdistan. A pleasant place?
米拉，我曾去过那里。是吗？我正要问你……高加米拉。我去过。你去了吗？我正想问你，因为我知道你去过伊拉克和库尔德斯坦一带。是的，所以高加米拉也被称为阿贝拉。是的。阿贝拉就是今天的埃尔比勒。我想它在主战场以南大约30英里处。所以那是库尔德斯坦。那是个宜居的地方吗？
No, it was awful. It was unbearably hot. Yeah, and dusty. The dust is going to be important. Yes, very, very dusty. So unbearably hot. Yeah. And dusty. The dust is going to be important. Yes. Very, very dusty. So that was very exciting. Yeah.
不，糟透了。热得令人窒息。是的，而且尘土飞扬。尘土将是一个关键因素。是的，非常非常尘土飞扬。所以热得令人窒息。是的。而且尘土飞扬。尘土将是一个关键因素。是的。非常非常尘土飞扬。所以那真是非常令人兴奋。是的。
So I made our fixer. We were making a film out there. I made the fixer do a diversion just so I could see it. Did you? Oh, that's great. I'm very envious. And was there anything to see at all? No, nothing.
所以我让我们的制片联络人——我们在那儿拍一部电影——我让那个联络人绕了个弯，只为了让我能去看一眼。是吗？哦，那太棒了。我太嫉妒了。那有什么可看的吗？没有，什么都没有。
Absolutely nothing. Disappointing. No. So yes, the Macedonian army just keeps coming. They keep going and going and going and then the story goes that they arrive in i think october 331 and alexander goes to the top of this hill and looks out and he thinks oh god that is a very big persian army because the sources the greek sources claim that derise had a million men which i think is very unrealistic but some people we're unrealistic. But some people say they think he maybe had 100,000 and Alexander had about half that. And he's got chariots.
绝对什么都没有。令人失望。没有。所以，马其顿军队一直在前进。他们不停地走啊走啊走，然后故事说他们在公元前331年10月左右抵达，亚历山大走到这座小山的顶端向外眺望，他心想：天哪，那是一支非常庞大的波斯军队。因为记载——希腊文献声称大流士有一百万军队，我认为这非常不切实际，但有些人……我们觉得不切实际。但有些人说他们认为大流士可能有一万军队，而亚历山大约有一半。他有战车。
He's got elephants. He's got the whole works. And you can tell that Alexander is worried because he doesn't attack straight away. And he forms a camp and he takes a few days to kind of think about it. And then he decides, OK, we're going to attack. And then there's this extraordinary story, which I'm sure you will say is made up that he goes to sleep. And the next day, all his captains get ready and they've all got kind of,
他有大象，应有尽有。你能看出亚历山大很担心，因为他没有立刻发动进攻。他建立了一个营地，花了好几天时间来考虑。然后他决定，好吧，我们要进攻了。接着有一个非同寻常的故事——我确信你会说那是编造的——说他去睡觉了。第二天，所有的指挥官都准备好了，他们都涂了油或者做了战前准备，但他还在睡觉，在他醒来之前他们都不能吃早饭，而他还是不醒。最后帕曼尼翁走进帐篷说：你怎么了？
you know, oiled up or whatever they do before battle. And he's still in bed and they can't have their breakfast until he wakes up and he still doesn't wake up. And eventually Parmenion goes into the tent and says, what's wrong with you? Yeah. How can you oversleep today of all days?
你怎么偏偏在今天这个日子睡过头了？
And Alexander says, well, it's because the one day where I'm'm not worried i know we're going to fight and we're going to win do you think he really said that tom i think that's absolutely bound to have happened it has it has the it has a slap of absolute authenticity something else very very plausible happens immediately afterwards you know they they get they get on his horse and he says to all his men uh he gets on bucephalus and he says you know we're about to win zeus is with us and then do you know what they see overhead in the sky an eagle the messenger of the gods of zeus a sign that they're going to win and i'm sure that absolutely happened because it's in the sources yeah yeah i'm sure i'm sure um anyway they win it's very dusty, isn't it? It's very dusty.
亚历山大说：哦，这是因为在这一天里我一点也不担心，我知道我们要去打仗并且会赢。汤姆，你觉得他真的说过这话吗？我认为这绝对是必然发生的事情。它带有绝对真实性的印记。紧接着又发生了一件非常非常合理的事情，你知道的，他们让他骑上马，他对所有人说——他骑上布塞法罗斯（Bucephalus），他说：我们要赢了，宙斯与我们同在。然后你知道他们在头顶的天空中看到了什么吗？一只老鹰，众神之王宙斯的信使，这是他们必胜的征兆。我确信这绝对发生了，因为文献里就是这么记载的。是的，是的，我确信，我确信……不管怎样，他们赢了。这里到处都是尘土，对吧？到处都是尘土。
It's all confusion. The Persians all run away. And there's a big gap opens up in the Persian line. Yeah. And Alexander and his cavalry, straight in. Exactly so. Exactly. And this time, Darius doesn't run away.
到处都是混乱。波斯人全都逃跑了。波斯人的防线出现了一个巨大的缺口。是的。然后亚历山大和他的骑兵直接冲了进去。完全正确。这一次，大流士没有逃跑。
Like a dagger thrust into the innards of Persian militarism, Dominic. Very good, Tom. You should try writing popular history books. i think you'd be a natural so this time darius is unlucky his men run away but he doesn't run away at first then he he runs away in a very confused way so it's not clear whether he's already a prisoner of bessus or whether bessus is or what's going on but anyway he's vanished and they can't catch up with up into media exactly so now Exactly. So now Alexander goes, he occupies Babylon. Is it not passing brave to be a king and ride in triumph through Persepolis? That's the next target.
就像一把匕首刺入波斯军国主义的心脏，多米尼克。说得好，汤姆。你应该去写通俗历史书，我觉得你在这方面很有天赋。所以这一次，大流士很不走运，他的手下都逃跑了，但他一开始并没有逃跑。然后他以一种非常混乱的方式逃跑了，所以目前还不清楚他当时已经是贝苏斯的俘虏，还是贝苏斯在……或者到底发生了什么。总之，他消失了，他们无法追上他，一直追到米底。完全正确。所以现在亚历山大去了，他占领了巴比伦。成为国王并以胜利者的姿态骑马穿过波斯波利斯，难道不是一件无比英勇的事吗？这是下一个目标。
Yeah. So he takes Babylon, he takes Susa, he fights another battle with some Persians, smashes them, and then he gets to Persepolis. This is the heartland, isn't it, of Persia, this beautiful city. I mean, at this point, the Greeks must be thinking, and the Macedonians must be thinking, you know, wow, this is on a scale that we've never seen before. And of course, they behave very badly. Well, this is one of the great moments in Alexander's career that people debate. Okay, so we have a question here from Joshua D. Terry. To what extent was Alexander's conquest of Persia actually intended as revenge for campaigns of Darius I and Xerxes in the 5th century BC?
是的。所以他占领了巴比伦，占领了苏萨，跟一些波斯人打了一场仗，把他们击溃了，然后他到达了波斯波利斯。这是波斯的核心腹地，对吧，这座美丽的城市。我的意思是，此时此刻，希腊人和马其顿人一定在想：哇，这是我们从未见过的宏大场面。当然，他们的行为非常糟糕。好吧，这是亚历山大职业生涯中备受争议的重大时刻之一。好吧，这里有一个来自约书亚·D·泰瑞（Joshua D. Terry）的问题。亚历山大对波斯的征服，在多大程度上是为了报复公元前5世纪大流士一世和薛西斯（Xerxes）的远征？
So those are the kings. Darius sends expedition to Marathon. Xerxes led the great expedition that ends up burning Athens in 480 BC. We mentioned in the previous episode that Philip has been using this as a kind of justification to get the Greeks on board. Alexander turns up in Persepolis. Persepolis, of all the great Persian capitals, is the one that's most associated with the Achaemenid dynasty, the dynasty of Persian kings, to which Darius III belongs. In Babylon and in Susa, Alexander has behaved with exemplary forbearance. In fact, at Susa, he allows the Persian commander of the citadel there to stay in office.
这些就是那些国王。大流士派遣远征军进攻马拉松。薛西斯领导了那场著名的远征，最终在公元前480年烧毁了雅典。我们在上一集里提到过，腓力一直以此为借口来争取希腊人的支持。亚历山大出现在波斯波利斯。在所有伟大的波斯首都中，波斯波利斯是与阿契美尼德王朝（Achaemenid dynasty，即大流士三世所属的波斯国王王朝）联系最紧密的城市。在巴比伦和苏萨，亚历山大的表现可以说是无可挑剔的宽容。事实上，在苏萨，他允许当地的波斯城堡指挥官继续留任。
So he's already accommodating himself to the local elites when he's... Absolutely. And due course, he's going to appoint, I think, a Persian as satrap of Babylon. So essentially, he's already, you know, he's a great general, isn't he? I mean, he's top general. But he's also a brilliant, brilliant political strategist. He clearly has this astonishing ability to read a situation politically as well as militarily. And he understands in a way that many, many of the Macedonians don't, that the only way that he can possibly hope to establish Macedonian rule over this vast empire that he's conquered is in a sense to get the Persians on board. I think that's absolutely right, Tom. Step into the platform heels of the great king himself.
所以当他……时，他已经在适应当地的精英阶层了。绝对是的。而且在适当的时候，他将任命一个波斯人担任巴比伦的总督。所以本质上，他已经——他是一位伟大的将领，对吧？我的意思是，他是顶级将领。但他也是一位极其杰出的政治战略家。他显然拥有在政治和军事上敏锐洞察局势的惊人能力。他以许多马其顿人所不具备的方式理解到，他要想在这个自己征服的庞大帝国中确立马其顿的统治，唯一的办法就是在某种程度上把波斯人拉拢到自己这边。我认为这绝对是正确的，汤姆。踏上伟大国王本人的高跟鞋。
I think he's more imaginative than some of his comrades. Vastly more imaginative. I mean, he's one of the most imaginative rulers who's ever lived so he sees straight away i think when he gets there this isn't now just a matter of like making ourselves very rich going back and buying a big farm in macedonia no this is he certainly thinks the machine is ripe for the taking i can i don't need to smash up the machine you decastrate it and you yeah i'll take it over i'll it over. I'll take it over. I'll do, you know, I'll take it over and get it to work for me. I can be the next Persian king.
我认为他比他的一些同僚更有想象力。远比他们更有想象力。我的意思是，他是人类历史上最具想象力的统治者之一，所以他一到那里就立刻看出：这不再仅仅是让自己变得非常富有、然后回马其顿买个大农场的问题了。不，这……他当然认为这个国家机器已经成熟，可以为他所用，我不需要砸碎这个机器，你只要把它据为己有，然后……是的，我会接管它，我会接管它。我会接管它，让它为我工作。我可以成为下一个波斯国王。
I think that's basically what he thinks. And why wouldn't you be? It's a much better thing to be, as we've talked about in our Persian episode, it's a much better thing to be the leader of Persia than the leader of Macedonia. But ideally, be both. Well, exactly. He can be both. That's what he's thinking. He thinks he can be ruler of everything. And pharaoh of Egypt. And he ideally, it'd be both. Well, exactly. He can be both. That's what he's thinking.
我想这基本上就是他的想法。为什么不呢？正如我们在波斯那一集里讨论过的，成为波斯的领袖比成为马其顿的领袖要好得多。但理想情况下，两者兼得。好吧，没错。他可以两者兼得。这就是他的想法。他认为自己可以成为一切事物的统治者。还有埃及法老。而且他理想情况下，可以两者兼得。好吧，没错。他可以两者兼得。这就是他的想法。
He thinks he can be ruler of everything. And pharaoh of Egypt. And he can. Of course he is. And he's king of the world in Babylon. I mean, he takes over all these titles. Although, interestingly, he never actually takes over the title of king of kings. So that's a step too far.
他认为自己可以成为一切事物的统治者。还有埃及法老。他确实做到了。他当然做到了。他在巴比伦就是世界的国王。我的意思是，他接管了所有这些头衔。不过有趣的是，他实际上从未接受过“万王之王”的头衔。所以那是一步过头了。
A step too far. But he does take over the kind of the regional ones. So he treats Babylon and Susa as a persian king would treat babylon and susa yeah but then persepolis is different because persepolis is the dynastic capital of the eucalyptus so what's he going to do with it and he basically he ends up deciding he's going to burn it well this is the question because some sources the great story is that they're having a great sort of drinking and so this is what ties in with joshua terry's question about is it revenge for yeah the burning so some people
过头了一步。但他确实接受了那些地区性的头衔。所以他对待巴比伦和苏萨的方式，就像波斯国王对待巴比伦和苏萨的方式一样。是的，但波斯波利斯则不同，因为波斯波利斯是阿契美尼德王朝的都城，那他要拿它怎么办呢？他基本上最后决定把它烧毁。好吧，这就是问题所在，因为有些文献记载，伟大的故事是说他们当时在大肆饮酒狂欢，这正好与约书亚·泰瑞的问题联系起来——这究竟是不是为了复仇？
say he does this as policy he always meant to do it and he deliberately said i'm going to burn down this fantastic columned hall and all these wooden ceilings and stuff as revenge deliberate revenge for the destruction of the temples but then other sources say no they're having a great evening and this is the first point at which you realize that they've actually not come without female company. They've brought all their girlfriends with them and courtesans. Athenian prostitutes. Athenian prostitutes. Yeah.
有些人说他这样做是出于政策需要，他一直都打算这么做，并且故意说：我要烧毁这座宏伟的柱廊大厅和所有木制天花板，以此作为对神庙被毁的蓄意报复。但另一些文献则说，不，他们当时正在开心地过夜，而这也是你第一次意识到，他们其实并不是没有女伴同行的。他们把自己的女朋友和交际花都带来了。雅典妓女。雅典妓女。是的。
So Ptolemy has this favorite called, what's she called? Teis. Is something like that? I don't know how you would pronounce it. And she says, they're all absolutely hammered. And she says. She's Athenian. Yeah, she's Athenian.
所以托勒密有个最喜欢的交际花叫什么来着？泰伊斯（Teis）？类似这样的名字？我不知道该怎么发音。她说——他们当时都喝得酩酊大醉。她说道——她是个雅典人。是的，她是雅典人。
She says, you know, you've done a really good job, job Alexander but why don't you let me but lead us in burning down Persepolis and he says oh great idea and so they all get torches and they burn it down and historians have argued ever since is this did she really do this I think you don't think so no I don't I think she did I like that's a great story It is a great story. And the thing about Alexander is he attracts great stories, like Blotting Paper Soaks Up Ink. Clearly, he burns down Persepolis. But the question is, why does he do it? Yeah. And the interesting thing, though, Tom, is when you read the academic historians, they divide pretty much 50-50 on all the big questions. And it's clearly because some can't bring themselves to let go of the story they read when they were about nine well i i mean you know we don't know we don't know i mean you know got to toss a coin you could say he did it uh and clearly i i would suspect and this depends
她说：你知道的，亚历山大，你干得真漂亮，但为什么不让我带头烧毁波斯波利斯呢？他说：哦，好主意！于是他们都拿着火炬把它烧了。从那以后历史学家们一直在争论：她真的这么做了吗？你觉得没有吗？不，我不这么认为。我觉得她确实做了。我喜欢这个故事，这真是个好故事。这确实是个好故事。而亚历山大的特点在于，他总能吸引各种精彩的故事，就像吸墨纸吸墨水一样。显然，他确实烧毁了波斯波利斯。但问题是，他为什么要这么做？是的。不过有趣的是，汤姆，当你阅读学院派历史学家的著作时，他们在所有重大问题上的看法几乎是平分秋色的。这显然是因为有些人无法割舍他们大约九岁时读过的那些故事。好吧，我的意思是，你知道的，我们并不知道，我们不知道，我的意思是，你知道的，这就像抛硬币一样。你可以说他是为了……而且显然我会猜测——这取决于对亚历山大的评价，但我会赞赏亚历山大的政治智慧。显然，烧毁波斯波利斯会很合国内希腊人的心意。亚历山大一直都在关注希腊。当时国内有些动荡，有些……你知道的，斯巴达人还在捣乱，雅典人也躁动不安。在某个时刻，亚历山大要把希腊人送回国内。他需要把希腊人拉拢在身边，所以烧毁波斯波利斯，他可以把它宣称为是对雅典被薛西斯烧毁的报复。是的，内心里我觉觉得这可能说得通。而且我认为这也说明了问题：波斯波利斯并不是最大的城市，最大的城市是巴比伦，而他并没有袭击最大的城市。好吧，波斯波利斯，当然了，
on rating alexander but i would rate Alexander's political intelligence. Obviously, burning down Persepolis is going to play well with the Greeks back home. And Alexander is always looking back to Greece. There's been kind of stirrings, there's been kind of, you know, the Spartans are still playing awkward, the Athenians are restive. At some point, Alexander is going to send the Greeks back home. He needs to keep the Greeks onks on board so burning down persepolis he can pitch that as being revenge for athens yeah by xerxes i i deep down i think that probably makes sense and i think it's also telling persepolis is not the biggest city the biggest city is babylon and he doesn't hit the biggest city well persepolis yeah of course persepolis
波斯波利斯是可以牺牲的。这是一个伟大的……你知道的，烧掉它是一个绝佳的政治信号，但你其实并没有损失太多。而且，你也可以向波斯人解释说，你攻击的是那个王朝。是的，而不是波斯本身。不是波斯本身，因为你对苏萨表现出了尊重。从这一点开始，在烧毁波斯波利斯之后，亚历山大将不遗余力地表现他对波斯习俗的尊重。但接下来他做的事，汤姆，很有趣，因为他没有说：我接下来要留在这里统治。他说：大流士仍然在某个地方。他和贝苏斯一起逃跑了。
is expendable it's a great you know you burn that down. It's a great political message, but you're not really losing that much. But also, you can frame it to the Persians that you're attacking the dynasty. Yeah, not Persia itself. Not Persia itself, because you're showing respect to Susa. And from this point on, having burnt down Persepolis, Alexander is going to go to great pains to show his respect for Persian customs. But what he does next, Tom, is interesting because he doesn't say, I'm going to now stay and rule. He says, Darius is still out there somewhere. He's fled with Bessus.
我们不知道在哪里。我们去追他。于是他们都去追他了。确实如此。到了这个时候，贝苏斯已经决定自己当国王了。是的。于是他接管了权力，自称为阿尔塔薛西斯四世。然后亚历山大大流士因流血过多而濒临死亡，对吧？
We don't know where. Let's go after him. And so they all go after him. They do. And by this point, Bessus has decided that he wants to be king. Yeah. And so he takes over, calls himself Artaxerxes IV. And Alexander finds Darius bleeding to death, doesn't he?
他被抛弃了。没错。他被锁在一个轿子里。他们沿着通往东方呼罗珊（Khorasan）的大道狂奔。他们知道大流士就在他们前面。有一天他们停下来，在水井边看到一个破旧的老轿子、战车或大车之类的东西，他们走过去一看，里面是大流士，正在流血过多而死。他对找到他的人——一个叫波利斯特拉图斯（Polystratus）的人说：
He's been kind of abandoned. That's right. He's been chained in a litter. They're charging on the road, the great highway that leads to Khorasan in the east. They know that Darius is ahead of them. And they stop one day and they see this sort of battered old litter or chariot or cart or something by a well and they go and look and inside is darius bleeding to death and he says uh to the guy who finds him who's called polystratus
告诉亚历山大，感谢他照顾我的母亲和妻子，告诉他我将右手交给他。然后他就死了。当然，这又完全是另一个故事了。因为这其中的妙处在于，亚历山大现在可以将自己塑造成大流士三世的复仇者，这使得他——在烧毁了波斯波利斯之后——现在可以宣称：我是阿契美尼德王朝的继承人。从亚历山大说“我们必须赶快，我们必须抓住大流士并杀死他”，到变成“可怜的大流士被背叛了，我要为他复仇”，前后基本上就五分钟。是的，我要为他复仇。所以他们确实抓住了贝苏斯。不过还有很长的路要走，因为他们一直在前进，对吧？现在这又是另一个节点，这真的是你开始说“等等，有些非常诡异的事情正在发生”的时刻。因为换作任何人，都会觉得：好了，事情结束了，我是波斯新国王了，太棒了。
he says tell alexander thank him for looking after my mum and my wife tell him i give him my right hand and then he dies and of course which again is entirely another story which because the genius of this is alexander can now cast himself um as the avenger of deris the third which then enables him to cast himself you know having burnt down persepolis he can now say i am the heir of the acumenids in the case it's basically five minutes alexander goes from we must hurry we must catch deris and kill him so like poor darius betrayed i would avenge him yeah i would avenge so they do capture besos well there's a long way to go because they they keep going don't they now this is another point this is really the point at which you say okay something very weird is going on because anybody
好吧，你会吗？你不会追击他进入阿富汗。那太疯狂了。好吧，除了……正如我们在现代所知，阿富汗可能是强大勇士的摇篮。这里太远了。如果你有一个自称是波斯国王的人，
else would say that's it done i'm the new king of Persia. Great. Well, would you? You wouldn't chase him into Afghanistan. That's demented. Well, except that, you know, as we know in modern times, Afghanistan can be a womb of mighty warriors. It's so far away. If you've got a guy claiming to be the king of Persia,
他的所有死党都在那里，而且他们是极为精锐的骑兵，而你刚刚征服了波斯，还自称是波斯国王，我认为你绝对承担不起把他留在那里的后果。我认为这很奇怪的原因，也是我认为它更具争议的原因，是因为大约在这个时候，你开始听到马其顿高级指挥层内部出现不满情绪的首次报告。当然是因为没有人想去那里，因为正是在他们第一次进入阿富汗之后，亚历山大才发现了——据说是发现了——刺杀他的阴谋，而帕曼尼翁（他最主要的将军）的儿子菲洛塔斯（Philotas）也牵涉其中。于是他说：好吧，我们必须处死菲洛塔斯和帕曼尼翁。他真的这么做了。我认为这就是关键所在，因为很显然，当时有些人心里在想：等等，我来这里是为了待两年，赚点钱，我可没想过要走几千英里深入阿富汗——一个我从未听说过的地方。但我认为这并不矛盾，亚历山大有很好的战略理由去做他正在做的事。因为亚历山大基本上不得不开始……
and he's got all his pals up there, and they're amazingly proficient cavalry, and you've just conquered Persia, and you're claiming to be the Persian king, I don't think that you can afford to leave him up there. The reason I think this is odd, and the reason I think it is more contentious, is that this is about the point where you get the first reports of discontent among the
你知道的，他不再仅仅以马其顿人的身份思考，他开始以一个征服了波斯并必须将波斯人拉拢到自己阵营的马其顿人的身份思考，这是两码事。而普通士兵则不必理会这些。你完全可以理解，特别是考虑到今年这个特殊的年份，
macedonian high command of course because nobody wants to go up there because it's after they first gone to afghanistan that um uh alexander discovers supposedly discovers the plot to kill him and philotas who is the son of parmenian his chief general is in on it and he says right we've got to kill philotas and parmenian and he does and i think that's the point because it's clear that at that point some people i think are thinking hold on i came for two years yeah get some money out of it i didn't think i'd be going thousands of miles and into afghanistan a place i've never heard of but i don't think that contradicts the fact that alexander has good strategic reasons for doing what he's doing. Because Alexander basically is having to start,
来自欧洲的士兵绝对不想前往那个完全恐怖、疯狂、到处都是想要杀死你的人且根本无法攻克的地方——阿富汗。但你同样可以看出，亚历山大声称统治波斯的合法性，取决于他必须消灭该头衔的竞争对手。这也要求他，如果他要成为波斯帝国的国王，他就必须宣称对波斯人统治过的所有土地拥有主权。是的。而且这也印证了你的观点，汤姆。正是在这个时候，你开始听到关于他穿波斯服饰的首次报告。
you know, he's no longer thinking as a Macedonian, purely he's starting to think as a Macedonian who's conquered Persia and who has to get the Persians on board, which is a different thing. And the rank and file don't have to bother with that. And you can entirely accept, particularly in this year of all years,
他穿着波斯紫色斗篷。他戴着波斯王冕。那是用白色缎带系在额头上的。他开始要求他的手下：你们必须用波斯的方式向我问候，即匍匐礼（proskinesis），这基本上就是飞吻。它通常被描述为什么趴在地上亲吻地板，但其实并非完全如此。
that, you know, soldiers from Europe do not want to go heading up into Afghanistan, which is a completely terrifying, mad place full of people who want to kill you and impossible places to capture but you can equally see that alexander's claim to rule persia depends on him eliminating a rival to that title it also requires him if he's going to be in a king of the persian empire he needs to lay claim to all the lands that were ruled by the Persians. Yeah. And it's also to back you up, actually, Tom. This is the point at which you get the first reports of him wearing Persian clothes.
那是飞吻，对吧？你在晚宴上得向他们飞吻。好吧，这是一种说法。你觉得他们应该怎样？你觉得那是什么？不，我认为这比那更正式。我认为这是一种更正式的臣服手势。是的，他们交换飞吻之类的。
So he wears a Persian purple cloak. He wears a Persian diadem. So it's tied onto your forehead by a white ribbon. And he starts to ask his men. He says, you have to greet me in the Persian way, proskinesis, which is basically blowing it. It's often described as sort of groveling on the ground and kissing the floor, but it's not quite that.
这是一种正式的臣服手势。他随身带着一位历史学家，一个名叫卡利斯耐尼（Callisthenes）的历史学家。他是亚里士多德的侄子，对吧？是的，他是亚里士多德的门生。他作为远征随军历史学家同行，这再次证明了亚历山大受过良好的教育。但最终他卷入了阴谋。
It's blowing them a kiss, isn't it? You get to blow them a kiss at dinner. Well, that's one way of putting it. What do you think they should? What do you think it is? No, I think it's more formal than that. I think it is a more formal gesture of submission. Yeah, they exchange kisses and stuff.
这个舞文弄墨的历史学家拒绝行亲吻礼。亚历山大说：好吧，如果你不肯做，那我也不会给你飞吻。卡利斯耐尼说：哦，好吧，那我能接受。亚历山大对此感到极其愤怒。钢笔杀死了他。他们对他实施酷刑然后把他绞死，我想是这样的。
It's a formal gesture of submission. And he's travelled with a historian, a historian called Callisthenes. Who's Aristotle's nephew, right? Yeah, he's Aristotle's protégé. He's come as the expedition historian, which is yet more testimony to Alexander's educatedness. But ends up in the plot.
有些历史学家说他们把他关在笼子里到处游街，这太严厉了。尽管我能想到某些历史学家不会……是的。是的。无论如何，他们进入阿富汗了，对吧？他们抓住了贝苏斯。
This pen-pushing historian refuses to do the kiss. And Alexander says, well, if you won't do it, I won't give you a kiss. And he says, oh, well, I can live with that. Alexander's absolutely outraged at this. Pen kills him. They rack him and then hang him, I think.
所以他也遭到了酷刑。他也经受了严刑拷打而死。我们现在是在压缩时间。我的意思是，比起事无巨细地经历这场非常非常复杂的战役，现在更应该指出的是：他们在那儿呆了绝对长的一段时间。他们在那里呆了大约三年。那里的环境糟透了。确实糟透了。
Some historians say they carry him around in a cage, which is harsh. Although I can think of some historians that don't. Yes. Yes. So anyway, they're going into Afghanistan, don't they? They capture Bessus.
他们总是要么遭遇严寒，要么忍受酷热。有些地方，比如粟特岩（Sogdian Rock）。他们总是在攀登山岩。文献资料极其混乱，因为在不同的文献中，他们在不同的时间攀登不同的岩石。我根本不知道他们到底在哪里。所以有一些重复出现的主题，那就是亚历山大开始处死他最亲近的人。
So he's also tortured. He's tortured to death as well. We're now compressing years. I mean, this is the point to make rather than go through it blow by blow, this very, very complicated campaign. They are there for absolutely ages. They're there for about three years. And it's awful. And it is awful.
所以你提到了卡利斯耐尼。还有“黑色”克利图斯（Black Clitus）。是的，就是曾在格拉尼库斯河战役中救过他命的那个人。是的，在格拉尼库斯河救过他的人。据说他在一场充满杀戮的争吵中被杀了。在一场醉酒的、是的，醉酒的暴怒中。亚历山大忙着在阿富汗各地建立名为亚历山大港的城市，左一个右一个，到处都是。
They're always either too cold or too hot. There are places, the Sogdian Rock. They're always scaling rocks. And the sources are so confused because in the different sources, they're scaling different rocks at different times. I have no idea who they are. And so there are certain themes, which is that Alexander starts killing his nearest and dearest.
他娶了一个波斯总督的女儿。我想那个人就是占领了粟特岩的家伙。他叫奥克西亚特斯（Oxiartes）。奥克西亚特斯和他的女儿罗克珊娜（Roxana）。不过这很奇怪，汤姆，因为她并不是最显赫的结婚对象。
So you mentioned Callisthenes. He's also Black Clitus. Yeah, who saved him at the Battle of the Granicus. Yeah, who saved him at the Granicus. He gets killed supposedly in a murderous brawl. In a drunken, yeah, drunken rage. Alexander is busy founding cities called Alexandria, left, right and centre,
难道不是吗？在核心腹地有关系更好、更有权势的波斯贵族，他为什么大老远跑到那里去娶一个阿富汗蛮荒之地的女子呢？因为他极力想要安抚那里。好吧，这恰恰暗示了其实他陷入了绝境，这就是我一直觉得它所暗示的：他在阿富汗陷入了绝境。永远不要入侵阿富汗。但他赢了。他确实赢了。你看，我的意思是，如果——我不知道——拜登娶了毛拉（Mullah）的女儿或者别的什么人。
all over Afghanistan. He marries the daughter of one of the Persian satraps. I think he's the guy who has the Sogdun rock. He's Oxiartes. Oxiartes and his daughter, Roxana. Now, this is strange, though, Tom, because she's not the obvious person to marry.
是的，完全如此。我的意思是，我觉得那就是那种场景。这真是一个绝妙的比喻。乔·拜登，如果他飞进类似巴格拉姆空军基地之类的地方……看，这就是接受古典教育的好处。是的。这是显而易见、顺理成章的一步。
Is she? They're a better connected Persianian noblemen you know in the heartland yeah why does he go all the way out there and marry somebody from the wilds of afghanistan because he's desperate to to pacify it well that suggests exactly that he's in deep trouble actually that's what i always seem to suggest that he's in deep trouble in afghanistan never invade afghan. But he wins. He does. You see, I mean, you know, if, I don't know, Biden had married the daughter of Mueller or something.
我从没见他去爬过什么岩石。你见过吗？没有，没有，没有。无论如何，那里最终算是被安抚下来了。问题是，那些基石、那些希腊人的城市基石将会永存。是的，我们在我们的阿富汗播客里讨论过这一点。比希腊人在波斯本土的统治还要持久得多。
Yes, exactly. I mean, it's that kind of scenario, I think. It's a great image. Joe Biden, that would be, if he'd flown into like Bagram Air Base or something. You see, that's the benefit of a classical education. Yeah. It's the obvious, obvious step to take.
是的，这太不可思议了，对吧？这个希腊王国。所以它实际上是有效的。从某种层面来看这简直是疯狂，因为永远不要入侵阿富汗。但它同时也具有战略意义。我的意思是，他甚至超越了阿富汗。这就是亚历山大，对吧？他走到了乌兹别克斯坦和塔吉克斯坦。我的意思是，他甚至超越了阿富汗。这就是亚历山大，对吧？他走到了乌兹别克斯坦和塔吉克斯坦。
He would, I never saw him scaling any rocks. Did you? No, no, no. Anyway, so it ends up kind of pacified. And the thing is that, you know, those foundations, those Greek foundations will endure. Yeah, we talked about this in our Afghanistan podcast. Much longer than Greek rule in Persia itself.
我的意思是，这太令人震惊了。在那种时候，他们在那儿到底在干什么？他们离推特（社交网络）太遥远了。这真的令人震惊。我想这就是亚历山大的迷人之处，你可以把他的行为描绘成绝对的疯狂，也可以描绘成绝对稳健的坚定战略。也许两者皆有。
Yeah, it's incredible, isn't it? This Greek kingdom. So it is actually effective. It's mad on one level because never invade Afghanistan. But it does make strategic sense as well. I mean, he actually goes beyond Afghanistan. And that's Alexander, isn't it? He goes to Uzbekistan and Tajikistan. I mean, he actually goes beyond Afghanistan. And that's Alexander, isn't it? He goes to Uzbekistan and Tajikistan.
我认为在某个节点上他开始失控了。他个人对征服的日常流程等等产生了依赖，他只是不想回去了。我不这么认为。我认为这全是为了确保波斯的安定。
I mean, it's astonishing. At that point, what are they doing there? They're so far away from the tweets. It's really astonishing. And I guess that's the fascination of Alexander, is that you can cast it as either absolutely lunatic or absolutely solid strategic firm sense. And perhaps
但这无法解释他接下来要做的事，汤姆——入侵印度。是的，好吧，这说得通，因为印度曾是波斯帝国的一部分。显然，这就是他们已经在路上——我们在哪儿？公元前326年——所以他们已经在路上了……我的意思是，我得查一下。他们在那里呆了太久了。好吧，他们是在公元前334年入侵的。整整八年。他们精疲力竭了。他的士兵们经历过各种最可怕的环境。许多人已经阵亡。他们身上带着跟出发时完全不同的武器，不同的盔甲。
it's both. I think there's a point here where he's tipping. He's got addicted, personally, to the routine of the conquest and stuff, and he just doesn't want to go back. I don't think so. I think that it's about having to make Persia secure.
他们穿的已经不是出发时的衣服了。他们拖着一长串形形色色的随行人员的庞大辎重队伍。正是在这个时候，有人对他说——他们穿着不同的衣服。他们拖着一长串形形色色的随行人员的庞大辎重队伍。正是在这个时候，有人对他说：你想不想去印度，帮我们一把？他说：好啊，太棒了。不，事情不是这样的。根本不是这样的。
But that does not explain what he does next tom invade india yeah well it does because india was part of the persian empire there's a this is clearly the point at which they have been on the road for what are we three two six so they have been on the road i mean i have to look it up. They've been there so long. Well, they invade in 334. Eight years. They are knackered. His men have been through the most hideous conditions of all kinds. Lots of them are dead. They've all got different weapons that they set out with, different armour.
确实如此。他们从塔克西拉（Taxila）找来了一个人来到王庭说：“来帮我们一把吧。”但之所以这么做，是因为印度河是波斯统治边界的标志。因此，如果亚历山大声称自己继承了波斯帝国的武功，他就有合法的权力去征服它。但你和我一样清楚，他根本停不下来，一直在前进。所以他南下去了塔克西拉——大致相当于今天的伊斯兰堡。
They're not in their same clothes. They've accumulated this great baggage train of kind of hangers-on. And this is the point at which somebody says to him, They're in the same clothes. They've accumulated this great baggage train of kind of hangers-on. And this is the point at which somebody says to him, do you fancy coming to India, giving us a hand? And he says, great, yeah. No, it's not like that. It's not like that.
在那里他遇到了我们在上一集里讨论过的赤身哲学家。也就是那些“裸体智者”（Gymnosophists）。然后他前往杰赫勒姆河（River Jhelum），也就是希腊人所称的海达斯佩斯河（Hydaspes），在那里他遇到了波鲁斯国王（King Porus），波鲁斯基本上统治着旁遮普地区。好吧，“遇到”。好吧，他派人给波鲁斯带了个信，说：“我想见你。”波鲁斯说：“好啊，我也想见你。我在杰赫勒姆河岸等你。”
It is. They get a guy from Taxila who comes to the court and says, come and give us a hand. But the reason he's doing it is that the Indus is the line that marks the limits of Persian rule. And so if Alexander is laying claim to the spear one Persian empire, he is legitimately able to conquer it. But you know as well as I do that he just keeps going. So he goes down to Taxila, which is roughly modern day Islamabad.
“我会带着战车和庞大的军队来。”正值季风季节。是的，在季风季节。跟你的生命说再见吧。亚历山大说：“好啊，我也奉陪到底。”他赶到那里，在季风季节渡过河，击败了大象——这太惊人了——带着他长长的刺矛，汤姆，这就是长矛发挥作用的地方，也是那些大象纪念币出处的地方。是的。然后，你又展现出政治头脑了：波鲁斯没有被杀，亚历山大对波鲁斯说：“你打得非常英勇，你显然是个了不起的家伙，我们为什么不结为同盟呢？你可以基本上成为一个受封的总督。”波鲁斯说：“太好了！”于是他们成了好朋友。所以他基本上把波鲁斯的王国纳入了自己的势力范围。但随后，他又继续前进了。他的士兵们现在已经到了哀求的边缘：“求求你们，我们能回家吗？”“不，让我们继续深入印度吧”，因为他认为自己会到达世界的尽头。尽管这看起来荒谬而神话般，但他为什么不这样想呢？
There he meets the naked philosophers that we talked about in the last episode. The Gimli Sophists. He then goes to the river Jellum, the Hydaspes, as the Greeks call it, where he meets King Porus, who's basically in the Punjab. Well, meets. Well, he sends Porus a message, says, I'd like to meet you. And Porus says, great, I'd like to meet you too. I'll meet you on the banks of the Jellum.
所以你看，我认为这一切都被高度神话化了。当然是这样。当然，我的意思是，这就是文献资料的性质。但这就是……你知道的，他的那种“渴望”（pothos），他那种对……的渴望。是的。但除此之外，他为什么还要继续前进？痛哭流涕，因为没有新鲜的井水可以去征服了。那是埃里克·布里斯托（Eric Bristow）。
I'll be bringing elephants and a massive army. In a monsoon. Yes, in a monsoon. Say goodbye to your life and alexander says great i'm up for it too he pitches up he crosses the river defeats the elephants in a monsoon it's amazing with his big spears tom with this is where the big spears come in and this is where the elephant medallions come in yeah and then he's very again you're the political nows porus is not killed and alexander says to porus you fought tremendously well you're obviously
那是埃里克·布里斯托。年仅27岁。他为什么还要继续前进，汤姆？好吧，他真的继续前行了吗？好吧，实际上，他掉头了，不是吗？他们穿过了更多的河流。他们到达了许阿西斯河（River Hyphasis）。在那里发生了一个可怕的场景：他的士兵们，
a fine fellow why don't we become allies and you can become basically a glorified satrap and porus says great and so they become great pals so he basically incorporates porus's kingdom into his orbit as it were but then again he keeps going he still doesn't his men now at the point where they please can we go home no let's keep going into india because he thinks he keeps going. He still doesn't. His men now are at the point where they're like, please, can we go home? No, let's keep going into India because he thinks he's going to get to the end of the world. And although that seems laughable and mythological, why wouldn't he think that?
正处于季风季节，遭到大量毒蛇的袭击，他们痛苦不堪，遇到了印度人，他们问：“这是世界的尽头吗？我们能回去吗？”因为他们以为自己可以造船，然后从海上绕回希腊。而印度人却说：“这里其实根本不是世界的尽头，前面还有一大堆印度，还有更多的文明，非常凶猛的帝国。”其余的马其顿人说：“天哪，这绝对是回家的时候了。”而亚历山大却说：“不，太棒了，来吧，让我们去跟他们较量一番！”我认为围绕这一切的说法，我们找不到任何不是来自几个世纪后的证据。我们确实只有几个世纪后的记载，但我们知道……我们知道那些文献——所以你提到文献是几个世纪后才写成的。
So you see, I think all of this is very mythologised. Of course it is. Of course, I mean, that's the nature of the sources. But this is, you know, his pothos, his yearning, his… Yeah. But why else does he keep going? Weeping salt tears because there are no fresh wells to conquer. That's Eric Bristow.
所以你看，我认为这一切都被高度神话化了。当然是这样。当然，我的意思是，这就是史料的本质。但这你知道的，就是他的“普托斯”，他的渴望，他的……对。但除此之外，他为什么还要继续前进？流着咸泪，因为没有新的井可以去征服。那是埃里克·布里斯托。
That's Eric Bristow. Only 27. Why does he keep going, Tom? Well, does he keep going? Well, actually, he turns around, doesn't he? They cross more rivers. They get to the river Hyphasis. And there there's this dreadful scene where his men,
那是埃里克·布里斯托。年仅27岁。他为什么还要继续，汤姆？嗯，他真的继续了吗？其实，他转过身回去了，不是吗？他们穿过更多河流。他们到达了希法西斯河。在那里发生了可怕的一幕，他的手下，
who are in the monsoon, they've been attacked by lots of snakes they're very miserable and they've met Indians and they say is the end of the world there can we get because they think they're going to build ships and sail around back to Greece and the Indians say there's actually not the end of the world there's just a hell of a lot more India and there's more civilizations very fierce empires the others the rest of the macedonians say christ this is definitely time to go home and alexander says no great let's bring it on let's go and tackle them too i think that everything around this is we have no evidence for it that isn't centuries later we have centuries later but we know on the we know that those sources, so you mentioned the sources being written centuries later.
正值季风期，他们遭到许多蛇的袭击，非常痛苦，他们遇到了印度人，并问这里是不是世界的尽头，我们能不能到头了，因为他们以为自己要造船然后航行回希腊，而印度人说这里其实不是世界的尽头，后面还有一大堆印度，还有更多的文明、非常凶猛的帝国，其他的马其顿人说，天哪，这绝对是该回家的时候了，而亚历山大说，不，太棒了，来吧，让我们去征服他们。我认为关于这一切，我们找不到任何不是几个世纪后才出现的证据，我们只有几个世纪后的记载，但我们知道……我们知道那些史料，正如你所说，这些史料是在几个世纪后才写成的。
They are Arian, Quintus, Curtis, Rufus, Diodorus, Plutarch, and so on. We know that they are compiled from originals that are now lost. So Clytarchus, Callisthenes, Nearchus, Aristobulus, Ptolemy, some of whom were Alexander's mates and wrote accounts of what happened. But they haven't survived, have they? No, but we know that these secondary sources that we're using... But we have no idea what was in them. Because they quote them.
他们是阿里安、昆图斯、柯蒂斯、鲁弗斯、狄奥多罗斯、普鲁塔克等等。我们知道这些都是根据现已失传的原著汇编而成的。比如克利托库斯、卡利斯提尼、尼阿库斯、阿里斯托布鲁斯、托勒密，其中有些人曾是亚历山大的同伴，写过事发经过的记录。但这些都没有存留下来，对吧？是的，不过我们知道我们正在使用的这些二手资料……但我们根本不知道里面写了什么。因为他们引用了这些资料。
Because they say, so-and-so says this, so-and-so says this, I think this. No, I think that all this stuff is actually about Rome. All these stories are about Rome. I know you think that. But I think you're an outlier and historians of Alexander don't agree with you. And what I would further say is that I think it's also about constructing the myth of Alexander as a kind of Achilles figure who never knows when to stop. So you don't think that happened? So you, unlike all historians of Alexander, think that the mutiny didn't happen? I think there probably was a mutiny. I don't know. I mean, I don't know. I don't know. He's backing down already. No, what I think is that
因为他们说，某某人这么说，某某人那么说，然后我认为这样。不，我认为所有这些内容实际上都是关于罗马的。所有这些故事都是关于罗马的。我知道你是这么想的。但我认为你是个特立独行的异类，研究亚历山大的历史学家并不赞同你的观点。我还要进一步说的是，我认为这也关乎将亚历山大塑造成一种阿喀式的神话人物，一个永远不知道何时收手的人。所以你不认为那件事发生过？所以你，和所有亚历山大历史学家不同，认为哗变根本没有发生过？我认为可能确实发生过哗变。我不知道。我是说，我不知道。我不知道。他已经开始退缩了。不，我的意思是
Alexander reaches the Indus. He reaches the Hydaspes. He reaches the limits of what had been Persian rule. And that's where he turns back. And it seems to me a striking coincidence that he should turn back exactly at the point where Persian rule ends, unless there is significance in the fact that he's reached the limits of the Persian Empire. Okay. And so I also think that by the time that these stories come to be written, there's a lot of interest in the idea of kind of limitless empire, where the idea of as um someone who is pushing to the absolute ends of the earth he's becoming he's kind of starting to be transmuted into myth somebody who and and what what the mutiny does is to give alexander a reason to turn around and go back that doesn't make him look too bad well the stories that we have are that he cried that he was sulking and he does
亚历山大抵达了印度河。他抵达了杰赫勒姆河。他抵达了波斯统治范围的极限。正是在那里他折返了。在我看来，一个惊人的巧合是，他恰好在波斯统治结束的地方折返，除非他抵达波斯帝国极限这一事实本身具有某种重大意义。好的。因此我还认为，等到这些故事被书写下来的时候，人们对无国界帝国的概念产生了极大的兴趣，这种概念作为一个努力开拓到世界绝对尽头的人，他正在开始被转变成神话，一个……而哗变所起到的作用，就是给亚历山大一个转身回去的理由，这让他看起来不至于太糟糕。好吧，我们拥有的故事是说他曾哭泣、怄气，而且他在
behave very suicidally and self-destructively afterwards. So I think he genuinely did want to go on. Anyway, you know what? We are in danger of very Alexander-like behaviour because we should take a break now and then we should return and we've got the Desert March to talk about and his death and then reputation.
事后表现出非常具有自杀倾向和自我毁灭的行为。所以我认为他内心深处确实想继续前进。不管怎样，你知道吗？我们正面临着表现得非常像亚历山大的危险，因为我们现在应该休息一下，然后回来，我们要谈谈沙漠行军、他的死以及他的声誉。
So see you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com that's therestisentertainment.com so dominic on uh yesterday's episode we talked about um this thing that we're doing in leicester
那一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的八盒八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们会拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、独家番外剧集并抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。所以，多米尼克，在昨天的一集中我们谈到了……我们将在莱斯特
square yeah the event of the season this sunday and we demonstrated our proficiency uh talking about cinema and history which which is the theme. And we hadn't even seen that film. Neither of us had seen. We were talking about Oliver Stone's Alexander. So just imagine what we'd be like talking about films we have seen. I mean, just extraordinary.
广场举办的活动……是的，这个星期天本季最盛大的活动，我们展现了自己讨论电影和历史的专业素养，这也是本期主题。而我们当时甚至还没看过那部电影。我们俩都没看。我们当时在讨论奥利弗·斯通的《亚历山大》。所以试想一下，如果我们讨论的是自己看过的电影会是什么样。我是说，简直非同凡响。
There's only one way to find out, isn't there? Because we will, we will be talking about films we have actually seen. I promise. And so we're doing that. That's this coming Sunday, the 14th of November at five o'clock, the Odeon Leicester Square.
只有一个方法可以知道，不是吗？因为我们会，我们将会讨论我们真正看过的电影。我保证。所以我们要这么做。就在这个星期天，11月14日五点钟，莱斯特广场欧迪恩影院。
And it's written here, genuinely looks like it's going to sell out. Genuinely looks. Genuinely. So we're not just lying when we say hurry, because there are very few tickets left. Yeah, there are not many tickets left, but there are some tickets left. So you do, if you listening to this very very few and they are so prized you would not believe so this is absolutely your last chance you have been warned i don't want to have to tell you again uh please end up giving money to touts yeah to encourage that do we yeah you definitely don't want okay
这里写着，看起来真的要卖光了。真的看起来是这样。真的。所以当我们说赶快时并不是在撒谎，因为剩下的票已经非常少了。是的，剩下的票不多了，但确实还有一些票。所以如果你在听这个……票数非常非常少，而且极其珍贵，你简直无法想象，所以这绝对是你最后的机会，你已经被警告过了，我不想再提醒你一遍，请最后去把钱送给黄牛党，对吧，去鼓励这种行为，是吗？你绝对不想这么做，好吧。
so i'm going to read something else a bit here it's look for podicon p-o-d-i-c-o-n on ticketmaster or just search for rest is history live is how you can get those gold dust tickets yeah we will see you there we cannot wait we're so excited aren't we tom we are yeah of course we are so see you then get your tickets and uh on with the show. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Alexander, for whatever reason you care to think, has turned around in India. He's going to come home.
那我再读一点别的内容。在 Ticketmaster 上搜索 podicon（P-O-D-I-C-O-N），或者直接搜索“Rest is History Live”，这就是你获得那些千金难求的门票的方法。是的，我们到时见，我们已经迫不及待了，对吧，汤姆？当然是，我们当然很期待，所以到时见，买好票，然后继续我们的节目。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。不管你出于什么原因认为，亚历山大已经在印度折返了。他要回家了。
The journey home is more complicated than you might think because, Tom, he doesn't go back the way he came. He decides he's going to go back through a desert. A terrible desert that wiped out cyrus's army yeah the cyrus the great failed to cross so he says well i'm well he sends his fleet and on the coast and he and his men are going to march through the desert and this all goes horribly wrong doesn't it but he does he does better than cyrus well he managed it but he loses so he's got bragging rights, save a Cyrus. He loses colossal numbers of men.
回家的旅程比你想象的要复杂得多，因为，汤姆，他没有按原路返回。他决定穿过一片沙漠回去。一片可怕的沙漠，曾经让居鲁士的军队灰飞烟灭。是的，居鲁士大帝未能成功穿过，所以他说，嗯，我很好……他派遣他的舰队沿海岸前进，而他和他的部下将步行穿过沙漠，这一切都极其糟糕地出了问题，不是吗？但他做得比居鲁士好。嗯，他成功通过了，但他付出了……所以他有吹嘘的资本，除了居鲁士之外。他损失了数量惊人的部下。
Yeah, yeah. They've had this huge baggage train of women and children with them who are all killed in floods. They don't get on with the locals who they call the fish eaters, who they say stink so badly that they can't go near them
对，对。他们带着庞大的妇女儿童辎重队伍随行，结果都在洪水中丧生。他们与当地人相处不融洽，当地人被他们称为“吃鱼的人”，他们说那些人身上的气味太难闻了，以至于他们根本无法靠近
to ask them for food. He loses touch with his fleet. Finally, after all this dreadful march which does seem a deluded thing to do i mean i don't think you're talking about strategic sort of genius there's absolutely no strategic sense really in the march the only explanation people have said is maybe he was really keen on the arab spice trade quite a long way isn't it hopefully check it out this way well except that except that he's he's marching along parallel to his fleet that's the point isn't it? Hopefully he can check it out this way. Well, except that he's marching along parallel to his fleet. That's the point, isn't it?
去向他们讨要食物。他与舰队失去了联系。最后，在经历了这场可怕的行军之后——这确实看起来是一件极其糊涂的做法，我的意思是，我不认为你在谈论战略上的某种天才，这场行军实际上根本没有任何战略意义，人们提出的唯一解释也许是他真的对阿拉伯香料贸易非常热衷。这路程可真够远的，不是吗？希望他能用这种方式去探索它。嗯，除了……除了他是一直与舰队平行行军的，这就是关键所在，不是吗？希望他能用这种方式去探索它。嗯，除了……除了他是一直与舰队平行行军的，这就是关键所在，不是吗？
So I think that's the... The claim is that actually he's really interested in the fleet and the fleet checking out ports and trade routes and stuff and that he's going to keep the fleet supplied from the land and that just goes horribly wrong. Anyway, he gets back. A series of mishaps happen once he... He established himself as a persian monarch doesn't he
所以我觉得……声称他实际上对舰队以及舰队对港口和贸易路线等的考察非常感兴趣，并且他打算从陆地上为舰队提供补给，而这结果却错得一塌糊涂。无论如何，他回去了。在他……将自己确立为波斯君主之后，发生了一系列的不幸，不是吗？
basically well he he so he's married roxana he now marries um i think it's dry as his daughter isn't it yes to terra yeah terra uh and another one as well yeah um and uh he holds this kind of great wedding where lots of macedonians have to marry lots of persians a big symbol there are two big symbols of that and then there's he tried he messes with the army and tries to reform the army, sending some back and bringing in Persians and Afghans. And so this is kind of what inspires Sir William Woodthorpe Tarn. Yes. Who is the great enthusiast for the idea that Alexander is a kind of prince of peace,
基本上，他娶了罗克珊娜，现在他又迎娶了……我想是大流士的女儿吧？是的，斯塔提拉。还有另一个……是的，还有另一个……还有……他举办了一场盛大的婚礼，许多马其顿人不得不迎娶许多波斯人，这是一个重大的象征，其中有两个重大的象征意义，然后他试图插手军队并试图改革军队，遣返一部分人并引入波斯人和阿富汗人。所以这就是某种程度上启发了威廉·伍德索普·塔恩爵士的东西。是的。他是一位狂热的拥护者，坚信亚历山大是一种和平君主，
who has a kind of United Nations approach. Champion of human rights. Champion of human rights, all that kind of prince of peace who has a kind of united nations champion of human rights champion of human rights all that kind of stuff um which generally i think people now don't totally buy into but he's the godfather of alexander studies isn't he because the key thing is that it's only the persians yeah alexander isn't really interested in other people's it's it's the persians and that's what alexander is all about that's why he's marrying what he's doing it's why he's wearing what he's wearing um he when he so when he gets back he um uh he promotes um one of his followers
拥有某种联合国式的方法。人权斗士。人权斗士，所有那种和平君主的风格，拥有某种联合国的风范，人权斗士，人权斗士，所有这些东西，总的来说，我认为现在人们并不完全买账，但他可是亚历山大研究的教父，不是吗？因为关键在于，只有波斯人，对吧？亚历山大其实对其他人的……这才是波斯人，这正是亚历山大所关注的全部，这就是为什么他要迎娶那些人，这就是他在做的事，这也是为什么他要穿着那些衣服。当他……所以当他回去时，他……他提拔了……他的一个追随者
i think to the rule of persia who has actually learned persian yeah i think he's yes and um i think that's really telling that's that's what this is all about and inevitably this there's a mutiny isn't there at oppis exactly and this is at oppis is where he basically gathers his men and he says i'm going to send a lot of you home now well done you're finished the quest is over and they cut up rough because they know they're being cut out of, basically, his new empire, and they're being supplanted by Persian replacements. And his court, he's got Persian secretaries.
我想是去统治波斯，那个实际上已经学会了波斯语的人。是的，我想是的，而且……我认为这真的很有说明意义，这正是这一切的关键所在。而不可避免地，这里发生了一场哗变，不是吗？在俄皮斯。没错，正是在俄皮斯，他基本上召集了他的部下，然后说：“我现在要遣散你们中的许多人，干得好，你们的任务结束了，探索已经结束了。”他们顿时大为光火，因为他们知道自己基本上被排除在他的新帝国之外了，而且他们正被波斯人的替代者所取代。在他的朝廷里，他配备了波斯秘书。
This is where this eunuch, Bagoas, comes in, who's clearly at Alexander's side a great deal. And he's now dressing in Persian outfits. The troops don't like it. They're kind of Macedonian farmers and stuff, and they feel that he's betraying them to this sort of foppish, luxurious, the very people that they had always been brought up to despise, I suppose. Do you think?
这就是那个太监巴高阿斯登场的地方，他显然经常陪伴在亚历山大身边。他现在穿着波斯服饰。军队不喜欢这样。他们基本上是马其顿的农民之类的人，他们觉得他是在把他们出卖给这种浮华、奢靡、也就是他们从小就被教育去鄙视的那些人，我想是的。你觉得呢？
Yeah, absolutely. Yes. And that makes sense. And I think that that's basically what's going on. The last sort of year of his life is very miserable because his great mate, Hephaestion, dies of fever. Alexander builds a monument to him, which still stands in Hamadan. You've been to Iran.
是的，完全如此。是的。这很合情合理。而且我认为这基本上就是当时发生的事情。他生命中的最后大约一年非常悲惨，因为他伟大的密友赫费斯提翁死于高烧。亚历山大为他建造了一座纪念碑，至今仍矗立在哈马丹。你去过伊朗吗？
I have. Yes, I have. Have you seen it? Yes. Oh, I'm very envious. And then what do you think? People say Alexander in the last year of his life is planning a new expedition. It's to Arabia, isn't it? Arabia.
我去过。是的，我去过。你见过它吗？见过。哦，我太嫉妒了。然后你觉得呢？人们说亚历山大在他生命的最后一年里正计划着一次新的远征。是针对阿拉伯的，对吧？阿拉伯。
Arrian has this brilliant line, which is really too good to be true. He says, even if Alexander had added the islands of the Britons to Europe, he would have still gone on looking for unknown lands. I think that's true. He'd invaded Iceland. Yeah, Greenland or something. Greenland. So he's sitting there and he's planning this new expedition to Arabia.
阿里安有一句精彩绝伦台词，真实得简直好得有点不真实了。他说，即便亚历山大将不列颠群岛并入欧洲，他依然会继续寻找未知的土地。我认为这是真的。他会入侵冰岛的。是的，格陵兰岛什么的。格陵兰岛。所以他坐在那里，正在筹划这次针对阿拉伯的新远征。
It seems the ships are all ready. He's drinking a lot. It's getting hot. He's in Babylon. And then he dies. And the question, which lots of people have asked, is, is he murdered or does he die of disease? What do you think, Tom? We have absolutely no way of knowing.
似乎船只都已经准备好了。他一直在酗酒。天气越来越热。他在巴比伦。然后他死了。许多人一直都在追问的问题是，他是被谋杀的，还是死于疾病？你觉得呢，汤姆？我们完全没有办法知道。
I think we do have a way of knowing. Do we? I'm much more certain than you about lots of these things uh he falls ill on the 28th of may 323 at a party with supposedly it's a party held by medias of larissa one of his officers he doesn't die till the 11th of june even the accounts that slightly disagree with that say he still doesn't die after between 10 to 14 days and most historians i think say that there aren't poisons that people use in the ancient world that take that long. And if you were going to assassinate him, you'd do it quickly. And you'd
我认为我们有办法知道。是吗？对于其中许多事情，我比你确定得多。他于公元前323年5月28日在一次聚会上生病，据说这场聚会是由他的军官之一拉里萨的墨地阿斯举办的。他直到6月11日才去世。甚至那些与此略有不同的记载也说，他无论如何也是在10到14天之间才去世的。我想大多数历史学家都会说，古代世界的人们使用的毒药没有需要这么长时间发作的。如果你打算暗杀他，你会速战速决。并且你会
have a succession plan in mind. And this is a place that's well known for malaria and other diseases. And it just makes sense. He's exhausted. He's drinking too much. It's hot. It's unhealthy. He gets malaria or something like that that that makes sense that he dies in about two weeks fits the symptoms i still think that that all these descriptions are so late ah so overlaid i i just i just don't think you can you can derive a medical diagnosis from i think accounts written i'd like to three or four hundred years now once we finish this podcast you should be emailing all the historians of Alexandra
心中早已盘算好继承计划。而这是一个以疟疾和其他疾病闻名的地方。这就说得通了。他精疲力竭。他饮酒过度。天气炎热。环境不健康。他得了疟疾或者诸如此类的病，这解释了他大约两周后死亡的原因，符合这些症状。我依然认为所有这些描述都太晚了，被添加了太多的修饰。我只是……我只是觉得你不可能……从这些编写于……呃，三四百年后的记载中推断出准确的医学诊断。一旦我们录完这个播客，你就应该给世界各地顶尖大学的所有亚历山大历史学家发邮件，告诉他们立刻停止这种做法。你已经看穿了他们的谎言。你知道的，我之所以没有写一本关于亚历山大的书的原因之一，就是我觉得
and leading universities across the world and telling them to desist forthwith. You've seen through their lies. You know, one of the reasons I haven't written a book on Alexandra is I just think
把这个故事讲得好像它基本上是一部浪漫小说那样的诱惑力实在是太强了。这就是为什么它作为一本儿童读物效果如此之好，因为你基本上……它就像是一部浪漫小说，对，诱惑力太强了，这就是为什么它作为一本儿童读物效果如此之好，因为你根本不用担心那种事情。对，但我认为……真是个扫兴鬼，汤姆·霍兰。历史和浪漫小说之间其实只有一条很窄的界限。是的，确实如此。正是这一点让这个故事如此激动人心。确实是这样。所以我们……
the temptation to tell the story like as though basically it's a kind of romance is so strong. And that's why it works so brilliantly as a children's book because you're basically it's a kind of romance yeah it's so strong and that's why it works so brilliantly as a children's book because you're not worrying about that kind of stuff yeah but i i think that um it's top killjoy tom holland it's it's it's a kind of narrow boundary between history and romance yeah it is that's what makes the story so exciting it is it is and so we It is. And so we have these stories that are written in the Roman period that we can treat
确实如此。所以我们拥有这些写于罗马时期的故事，我们可以把它们当作历史来对待，因为它们为我们提供了可辨认的地名。它们为我们提供了人物、动机、战役以及所有类似的东西，具有一种现实的虚象。但是汤姆，你对温泉关和萨拉米斯可没这么说。哦，没有，因为对于温泉关和萨拉米斯，我们知道提供主要资料的那个人曾与参与过的人交谈过。显然，他进行了加工润色。是的。
as history because they give us recognisable place names. They give us characters, they give us motivation and battles and all that kind of stuff that have the kind of semblance of reality. But Tom, you didn't say this about Thermopylae and Salamis. Well, no, because with Thermopylae and Salamis, we know that the guy who provides our main source spoke to people who fought with it. Clearly, he's elaborated it. Yes.
毫无疑问。但比起那些在几个世纪甚至几个世纪之后才撰写的的故事，它更扎根于所发生事件的现实之中，我认为。那些显然有据可依的故事，历史学家自己也说：“我是根据这个人来写的。我读过这本书。”我的意思是，他们对于自己在使用资料这一点上是完全坦诚和公开的。他们的确是。但这是不可能的。
No question about that. But it's more rooted in the reality of what happened, I think, than stories written centuries and centuries after. The stories that are clearly based on sources, that the historians themselves say, I'm basing this on this guy. I've read this book. I mean, they're completely upfront and open about the fact that they're using sources. They are. But it's impossible.
我们根本无法在它们之间做出判断。我的意思是，这并不是说其中一个……确实无法判断。是的。其中一个必定是真的。我的意思是，也可能没有一个是真的……我同意你的看法。确实无法判断。其中一个必定是真的。我的意思是，也可能没有一个是真的。是的，你说得对。这就是问题所在。
It's impossible for us to judge between them. I mean, it's not to say one. It is impossible to judge. Yeah. One might be. One must be true. I mean, none of them might be one... I agree with you. It is impossible to judge. One must be true. I mean, none of them might be true. Yeah, you're right. That's the problem.
这与穆斯林征服、阿拉伯征服的情况完全一样，要将这些视为某种历史事实、关于实际发生事情的详细叙述，其难度我认为是极大的。好吧。我认为亚历山大也是如此。
And it's exactly the same as with the Muslim conquests, the Arab conquests, that the difficulty in accepting these as kind of historical fact, detailed accounts of what actually happened, I think is profound. Okay. And I think the same is true with Alexander.
我认为这是一个精彩绝伦的故事。你知道，它是不错的儿童读物素材。它是极好的小说素材等等。但我认为你很难知道该如何把它作为历史来书写。好吧。所以托马斯发了一通关于……关于故事的发飙。是的，抱歉。
I think it's a brilliant story. You know, it makes for wonderful children's books. It makes for wonderful novels and so on. But I think that it's very difficult to know how you write it as history. Okay. So Thomas had his rant about, his rant about stories. Yeah, sorry.
而现在……但是另一个，但是另一个，但是另一个，你知道，另一个耐人寻味的现象，我认为突显了这一点，那就是这种方式：
And now... But the other, but the other, the other, you know, the other kind of intriguing thing, which I think highlights that, is the way in which,
即便这些被加上引号的所谓历史正在被撰写，你同时也能看到它们走向另一个方向的可能，那就是演变成浪漫故事和关于亚历山大越来越光怪陆离的传说，在这些传说中，他是阿蒙神的儿子。或者实际上，我的意思是，它最终在波斯传统中奇怪地演变成他是波斯人，是波斯国王的儿子或者是法老的儿子。
even as these, these kind of histories in inverted commas are being written, you're also seeing the other way in which they can go, which has become romances and increasingly fantastical stories about Alexander, in which he is the son of Amun. Or he is actually, I mean, it kind of ends up weirdly in Persian traditions that he's a Persian, that he's the son of a Persian king or a son of a pharaoh.
你会听到关于他去过世界尽头的种种故事。他坐过潜水艇，不是吗？他坐过由鸟儿吊起的热气球去过世界尽头的种种故事。你会听到关于他……他坐过潜水艇，不是吗？他坐过潜水艇，坐过由鸟儿吊起的热气球，诸如此类奇妙的故事。然后你开始看到犹太、基督教和穆斯林的传统。因此，犹太人不知道该如何对待他。你知道，他是个狂妄自大的疯子吗？他们最终的看法是，不，其实并不是。
You get stories about him going to the very ends of the earth. He goes in a submarine, doesn't he? He goes up in an air balloon lifted by birds very ends of the earth. You get stories about him. He goes in a submarine, doesn't he? He goes in a submarine, goes up in an air balloon, lifted by birds, kind of amazing stories. And you start to get Jewish, Christian, Muslim traditions. So the Jews are unsure what to do with him. You know, is he a kind of insane megalomaniac? They just end up thinking no, actually.
于是流传开这样一个传说：他去了耶路撒冷，并且基本上承认了在耶路撒冷受到崇拜的神。在基督教时期，他被转化成了一个基督徒，尽管很显然他出生在基督之前。然后他在《古兰经》中出场了，这可以说是最令人惊奇的了。他是双角者，或者他在《古兰经》里吗？他是朱尔·卡尔纳因（Dhul-Qarnayn），即双角者，这只能是阿蒙神的角。所以这是一个神奇的现象，他去锡瓦拜访阿蒙神谕的这次旅行的细节，在《古兰经》中产生了一种扭曲的回声，而《古兰经》本来是那种……你知道的，如此反对偶像崇拜、多神教和所有这类东西的。
So a tradition arises that he goes to Jerusalem and he basically acknowledges the God who's worshipped in Jerusalem. In the Christian period, he gets kind of transmuted into a Christian, even though obviously he's born before Christ. And then he appears in the Quran, most amazingly of all. He's the horned one, or is he in the Quran? He's the dulcanane, the two-horned one, which can only be the horns of Amun. So there's the amazing thing that the details of this trip to Siwa, where he goes to the Oracle of Amun, has this kind of distorted echo in the Quran, which is the kind of, you know, so opposed to idolatry and paganism and all that kind of stuff
而他却出现在那里，并且亚历山大在《古兰经》中，你知道的，这就是他的渴望（pothos），他前往世界的尽头，他是……但我们来谈谈……说到尽头，我们收到了很多听众关于遗产和帝国等方面的问题。所以乔纳森·怀尔德（Jonathan Wild）有一个问题：他的帝国是不是太大而无法持久？因为很显然，根据资料记载，在他临终时——而汤姆认为这些资料全都是编造的——他非常著名地说过，据他们说，你将把你的王国留给谁？他的摄政王佩尔狄卡斯对他说，最终在某种程度上成为了他的继承人的人对他说，你打算把王国留给谁？他说：“Toi Cratistoi”，给最强者。然后一切都土崩瓦解了。这群小伙子……随同他一起前来的这群小伙子们
and there he is and and alexander in um in the quran he's you know it's his pothos he's going to the limits of the earth he's but let's talk about um talking about limits we've got lots of questions from the listeners about legacy and empire and so on so jonathan wild has a question was his empire too big to last because obviously obviously on his deathbed, according to the sources, which Tom believes are all made up, he famously says, they say, to whom will you leave your kingdom? Perdiccas, his regent, says to him, who ends up basically being his successor in some ways, says to him, who are you going to leave your kingdom to? And he says, Toi Cratistoi, to the strongest. And then it all falls apart. The lads the sort of the lads who've come with
全都反目成仇，互相攻伐厮杀，最终塞琉古成为了基本上接管波斯和大部分亚洲地区的人，托勒密接管了埃及……他的其中一位将领安提帕特和他的儿子卡山德占据了马其顿，对吧？我不确定我是不是漏掉了一个人。哦，还有安提贡斯。安提贡斯，对了。独眼安提贡斯。他占领了小亚细亚，是这样吗？
him all turn on one another and they all fight and kill each other and it ends up with salukas is the guy who basically takes over persia and much of asia ptolemy egypt um his one of his generals antipater and his son cass, take Macedonia, don't they? I'm not sure I've missed somebody out. Well, you've got Antigonus. Antigonus, that's right. Antigonus, Antigonus the One-Eye. He takes Asia Minor, is that right?
不，他最初统治波斯地带、东部地带。对的。然后塞琉古从他手中接管了过来。好吧，所以这是一个非常像《权力的游戏》那样的场景，不是吗？问题是……问题是它本来能持久吗，汤姆？你认为它本来能持久吗？我认为如果亚历山大活下来，我认为如果他建立了一个稳固的继承体系，我认为这完全是可能的，并没有过大。他必须把权力的重心放在波斯，是的。而问题在于，他的继任者们，没有一个……没有一个马其顿小伙子愿意这么做。
No, he initially rules the Persian stretch, the eastern stretch. Right. And then Seleucus takes over from him. Okay, so it's a very Game of Thrones-style scenario, isn't it? The question it the question is could it have lasted tom do you think it could have lasted i think if alexandra had lived i think if he'd established a secure succession um i think it's perfectly possible not too large he would have had to say i mean he would have had to make the center of gravity in persia yeah and the thing is is that none of the uh none of his successors, none of the Macedonian lads want to do that.
所以塞琉古帝国的首都最终落在了安条克，也就是地中海沿岸。事实上，现在不叫叙利亚了吧？我想这是土耳其的一个奇怪区域，但基本上就是叙利亚。也就是土耳其的安塔基亚。是的。埃及，当然是地中海的。
So the capital of the Seleucid Empire ends up Antioch, which is on the Mediterranean coast. Actually, it's not Syria now, is it? I think it's this kind of weird chunk of Turkey, but it's basically Syria. It's Antakya in Turkey. Yeah. Egypt, of course, is Mediterranean.
马其顿是地中海的。他们不想去东方。但亚历山大想。如果亚历山大从苏萨、巴比伦或者其他什么地方进行统治，那么凭借他的声望、他的政治头脑，我认为他是能做到的。但他肯定会面临希腊等地的叛乱，不是吗？嗯，他可能会遇到，但他可能最终会觉得，好吧，我让希腊独立好了。而且，我的意思是，他在马其顿拥有一支庞大的、强大的军队。
Macedonia is Mediterranean. They don't want to be out east. Alexander did. And had Alexander ruled from Susa or Babylon or whatever, then, you know, with his prestige, with his political nous, I think he could have done it. But he surely would have faced revolts in Greece and so on, wouldn't he? Well, he might have done, but he might have kind of ended up, well, I'll cut Greece free. But also, I mean, he's got a massive, he's got a big force in Macedonia.
我认为阿契美尼德王朝统治的基础是存在的，而亚历山大理解它的价值，这就是为什么皮埃尔·布里安（Pierre Briant）称他为“最后一个阿契美尼德人”。他本可以……你知道，它本可以最终变成阿契美尼德王朝退场，而亚历山大的王朝基本上取而代之。是的，有点像埃及人，埃及人的那种方式……有点像埃及人，是的。有点像埃及在托勒密王朝之下的情形。但你所面临的问题是，亚历山大在他的一生中从未真正表现出任何兴趣，特别是……我知道他在与精英阶层打交道等方面表现出了极大的战略和政治头脑，
I think that the infrastructure of a Kaimanid rule is there and Alexander understands its value, which is why Pierre Brion calls him the last of the Achaemenids. He could have been, you know, it could have kind of ended up that the Achaemenids go and Alexander's dynasty basically takes its place. Yeah, rather like Egyptian, the way that Egyptians... A bit like the Egyptians, yes. A bit like the Ptolemies in Egypt. But the problem you have with that is that Alexander in all his lifetime has never really shown any interest, particularly... I know he's shown great strategic and political nous in dealing with elites and so on,
但他并没有特别表现出对单纯治理国家的兴趣。他表现出极大兴趣的是战斗。再说一次，我不确定这是不是真的。我认为他确实有，我认为他……你知道，他对总督的任命，他对军事组织、行政组织的关注，我认为……难道你不觉得在他生命最后一年里，他已经在考虑一次新的远征，这很能说明问题吗？我是说，歇一会儿吧老兄，你知道的，安定下来，建立一个王朝，你非要去阿拉伯吗？这就是我会认为的……再次重申，你
but he hasn't particularly shown an interest in just governing. He's shown a lot of interest in fighting. Again, I'm not sure that's true. I think he does i think he you know his his appointments of satraps his um his concern with um military organization with administrative organization i think it's but don't you think it's telling in the last year of his life he's already thinking about a new expedition i mean just take a break mate you know settle down found a dynasty do you need to go to arabia that's what i would see as the again you're
会说你……你根本不相信这一切发生过，我们不知道，这一切都是个梦，我们不知道，我们不知道。好吧，我们来谈谈……关于杰瑞和许多其他人，”萨姆说道，我们幕后的巨头萨姆说，他们都问：他的尸体在哪里？好吧，我们知道他的尸体最后大致落在了哪里，对吧？它最终留在了亚历山大港。未来的皇帝奥古斯都曾去那里瞻仰过它，并顺便敲掉了它的鼻尖。据说如此。
gonna say you don't you don't you don't believe any of it happens we don't it's all a dream we we don't we don't know okay let's um uh what about the so jerry and many others, says Sam, our backroom mogul. Sam says they've all asked where is his body? Well, we know where his body kind of ended up, don't we? It ended up in Alexandria. Where it gets visited by the future Emperor Augustus, who knocks off the tip of his nose. Supposedly.
现在，我其实不相信这个故事。我认为这个故事显然是虚构的。好吧，你知道那个精彩的故事吗？你知道关于他的尸体到底在哪里的那个高明理论吗？不，那就是……别告诉我在索尔不兹。不，是在威尼斯，因为威尼斯人来到亚历山大港寻找圣马可的遗体，因为那是圣马可……是的，马可的遗体本该埋葬在那里。
Now, I don't believe that story, actually. I think that story is clearly invented. Well, you know the brilliant story. You know the brilliant theory about where his body is no which is that um don't tell me it's in salisbury no it's in venice because the the venetians arrive in alexandria looking for the body of saint mark because it was san marco yeah mark mark's body is meant to be buried there um And they go in and it's a time of chaos in Alexandria. And they look around and they find this body in a kind of great shrine. And so they assume it's St. Mark's body
然后他们进去了，当时亚历山大港正处于混乱时期。他们四处搜寻，在一个宏伟的神社里发现了这具尸体。于是他们想当然地认为这就是圣马可的遗体，
and they remove it and they take it to Venice. And so Alexander's body is in San Marco. Do you believe that? I was about to say, you don't believe all these sources, but you believe that? It's such a good, It's such a great theory that I'd want to believe it. Now, there might be some people listening to this podcast who say, well, you've described somebody who fought a lot of battles and climbed rocks and behaved in sort of outlandish ways. But so what?
便将其运走并带回了威尼斯。所以亚历山大的尸体现在在圣马可大教堂里。你相信这个吗？我正要说，你连这些资料都不信，却相信这个？这是一个如此精彩……这是一个如此绝妙的理论，以至于我都想相信它了。现在，听这个播客的人中可能会有些人会说，嗯，你们描绘了一个打过很多仗、爬过悬崖、行为古怪的人。那又怎样？
You know, is it anything more than a children's? Is it anything more than basically the Lord of the Rings without the ring for adults? And does Alexander matter, do you think? I mean, obviously, he inaugurates what we call the Hellenistic Age, the idea of this synthesis of East and West. But do you think that would have happened anyway? Or do you think it took Alexander and his conquests to do it? Well, there's a famous saying by a German historian in the 20s, Karl Becker, who said,
你知道，这难道不就是一部儿童读物吗？难道它不就是没有魔戒的、适合成年人看的《指环王》吗？你认为亚历山大重要吗？我的意思是，很显然，他开启了我们所说的希腊化时代，即东西方融合的理念。但你认为这种融合无论如何都会发生吗？还是说你认为非得靠亚历山大和他的征服才能实现？好吧，20年代有一位德国历史学家卡尔·贝克尔（Karl Becker）有句名言，他说：
without Alexander the Great, no Islamic civilization. Yeah, and no Christianity, arguably, right? I mean... So he creates, he creates what becomes, you know, the koine, the common Greek language. But you could say that the culture
没有伟大的亚历山大，就没有伊斯兰文明。是的，可以说也没有基督教，对吧？我是说……所以他创造了……创造了后来成为……你知道的，通用希腊语（koine）。但你也可以说这种文化
becomes a kind of koine. It's a melting pot in which Greek, Persian, Mesopotamian, Jewish influences all kind of mix and mingle. And that is the Petri dish from which Christianity, rabbinical Judaism, Islam will emerge. And those are absolutely seismic developments. Yeah. So I think Alexander does matter. Yeah. seismic developments yeah so i think i think alexander does matter yeah i think also he matters doesn't he because of the model that he presents to pompey to we mentioned augustus okay
变成了一种通用语。这是一个大熔炉，希腊、波斯、美索不达米亚、犹太等各种影响在其中交融汇聚。而这就是基督教、拉比犹太教和伊斯兰教得以萌芽的培养皿。这些绝对是震撼性的发展。是的。所以我认为亚历山大确实很重要。是的，震撼性的发展。是的，所以……所以我觉得亚历山大确实很重要。是的，我还认为他之所以重要，难道不是因为他为庞培、为我们提到的奥古斯都树立了榜样吗？好吧，
so we've got a question from from gary hicks was alexander actually great and if so for what and in comparison to whom that takes us back to the as you said our very very first podcast where we talked about that um alexander it's again it seems to be the romans who call him the great um the earliest reference to him as great is in a play by a roman playwright called plautus uh in the early second century bc and he it seems to kind of derive from a desire to you know there are lots of Alexanders who were Macedonian kings. So he's Alexander who's the great. And the Romans have this, you know, the cognomen, which is a kind of like a descriptive word.
所以我们有一个来自加里·希克斯（Gary Hicks）的问题：亚历山大真的伟大吗？如果是的话，是为了什么？以及与谁相比？这就把我们带回了，正如你所说，我们非常非常的第一期播客，我们在那里谈论过这个……亚历山大，再次看来，似乎是罗马人称他为“大帝”。对他是“大帝”的最早记载出现在公元前二世纪初一位名叫普劳图斯的罗马剧作家的一部戏剧中，这似乎源于一种渴望，你知道的，有许多名叫亚历山大的马其顿国王。所以他是“大帝”亚历山大。罗马人有这种习俗，你知道的，第三名（cognomen），这是一种类似于描述性的词汇。
So the great is like a kind of Roman cognomen. And this is Pompey the Great who goes to the east and he conquers vast swathes of what had been Alexander's empire. And he brings back Alexander's cloak and sports it. I'm sure it definitely was Alexander's cloak. It's only like 300 years too late. And he adopts Alexander's hairstyle, this kind of Elvis quiff. Yes. And so that then beds down the idea of greatness.
所以“大帝”就像是一种罗马式的第三名。这就是庞培大帝，他前往东方，征服了曾属于亚历山大帝国的广袤领土。他带回了亚历山大的斗篷并将其穿在身上。我确信那绝对是亚历山大穿过的斗篷。这仅仅是迟了大约300年而已。他还采用了亚历山大的发型，也就是这种猫王式的卷刘风。是的。这便奠定了“伟大”的概念。
And of course, the Romans have an ambivalent relationship to that because... Of their distrust of kings, right? The distrust of kings, yes. And actually, the question, you know, Rome is meant to be an empire without limits, according to Virgil. What does that mean? And so that's why there's this fascination with a king, a conqueror, who dreams of an empire without limits. And I think that's a huge part of what's going on with these stories about Alexander.
当然，罗马人对此有着矛盾的情结，因为……由于他们对国王的不信任，对吧？对国王的不信任，是的。事实上，根据维吉尔的说法，罗马本来应该是一个没有疆界的帝国。那意味着什么呢？所以这就是为什么人们会着迷于一个梦想着建立无疆界帝国的国王、一个征服者。我认为这是关于亚历山大的这些故事背后极其重要的一个部分。
Didn't Caracalla, is it Caracalla, the son of Septimius Severus, didn't he model himself in Alexander as well? And he tried to set up his own phalanx and stuff. Isn't that right? Well, he invades Mesopotamia, as Alexander had done, and is killed while having a pee. That's right. He gets off his horse to go to the loo, and one of his men kills him. That would never have happened to Alexander. But they're always doing that. Crassus does it. Julius Caesar was preparing to do it before he gets assassinated. Mark Antony does it. Trajan does it. Caracalla does it. Julian the Apostate does it. They're all invading.
难道卡拉卡拉——是塞维鲁的儿子卡拉卡拉吗——他难道不也是以亚历山大为榜样吗？他还试图建立自己的方阵之类的。难道不是这样吗？嗯，他入侵了美索不达米亚，正如亚历山大曾经做过的那样，结果在小便时被杀。没错。他从马背上下来去上厕所，结果他手下的人把他给杀了。这种事绝对不会发生在亚历山大身上。但他们总是在这么做。克拉苏也是。尤利乌斯·恺撒在遇刺前也正准备这么做。马克·安东尼也是。图拉真也是。卡拉卡拉也是。背叛者尤里安也是。他们都在四处入侵。
And it all goes wrong for all of them and it always goes wrong and so and so that again burnishes the the legend of alexander as someone who could actually do it uh this absolutely i'm so glad you've said this because this comprehensively proves that i was right when i said alexander would beat julius caesar and mary beard refused to answer uh when we had her on the podcast talking about classics. We had that crucial question, who would win a fight? Lots of people have asked us more iterations of this question. Who would win a fight? Genghis Khan, Julius Caesar, Augustus, Napoleon, or Alexander?
而所有这一切对他们所有人来说都以失败告终，并且总是以失败告终，所以……所以这再次擦亮了亚历山大作为真正能做到这一点之人的传奇色彩。这绝对是……我太高兴你这么说了，因为这彻底证明了我之前的说法是正确的，当我断言亚历山大会击败尤利乌斯·恺撒时，玛丽·比尔德拒绝回答——当时我们邀请她上播客谈论古典学。我们抛出了那个至关重要的问题：谁会在决斗中获胜？许多人向我们提出了这个问题的更多变体。谁会在决斗中获胜？成吉思汗、尤利乌斯·恺撒、奥古斯都、拿破仑还是亚历山大？
I think my answer to that would be that obviously Alexander would win in a fight, but Augustus would win the peace. Do you know what I think? Yeah, I think so. I mean, they seem to me the two poles, actually, of leadership. They're the two great figures, the two great paradigmatic leaders of the ancient world. But Alexander's empire doesn't last, and Augustus's does.
我想我对这个问题的回答会是，很明显亚历山大会在决斗中获胜，但奥古斯大会赢得和平。你知道我觉得怎样吗？是的，我也这么觉得。我的意思是，在他们看来，这实际上是领导力的两极。他们是古代世界仅有的两个伟大人物，两位伟大的范式领袖。但亚历山大的帝国没有持久，而奥古斯都的帝国持久了。
And that moment when Octavian, at that point, when he's in the tomb looking at the body of Alexander, I mean, that's surely one of the extraordinary moments in all of history. Cleopatra has, I think, just died, just killed herself. And Octavian goes down and he goes to see the tomb of Alexander and sort of stares at it. And I think he leaves flowers or something.
而当屋大维——当时他还在那个陵墓里看着亚历山大遗体的那一刻，我的意思是，这绝对是所有历史中最非凡的时刻之一。克利奥帕特拉我想刚刚才死去，刚刚自杀身亡。然后屋大维走下去，去参观亚历山大的陵墓，凝视着它。我想他留下了花之类的东西。
And then they say to him, the attendants say, would you like to see the tombs of the Ptolemies now? He says, no, I didn't come to see dead men. I came to see a god. I came to see a god. And yeah, do you think people will, for hundreds of years, will still talk of Alexander in this sort of aude? Not if they've been listening to you dissing the sources, obviously.
然后他们对他说，随从对他说，你现在想去看看托勒密诸王的陵墓吗？他说：“不，我不是来见死人的。我是来看一个神的。我是来看一个神的。”是的，你觉得人们在几百年后还会带着这种敬畏谈论亚历山大吗？如果他们没有听你贬低那些历史资料的话，当然会。
I think so. And I think the reason for that is in that poem that we began this episode with, the Robert Lowell one, that you can say, yeah, his crimes are terrible. But they're not crimes, are they? They're not crimes by the standards of the age, they're not. Even remotely crimes. But, well, I don't know.
我认为会的。我认为原因就在于我们本集节目开头的那首诗，罗伯特·洛厄尔的那首诗里，你可以说，是的，他的罪行太可怕了。但它们其实不是罪行，不是吗？按那个时代的标准来看它们根本不是罪行，完全不是。甚至连沾边都算不上，但，嗯，我不知道。
I mean, people at the time didn't say he's a bad man, he's a bad king. Yes, I think they did. I mean, I think the scale of the slaughter at Tyre. That's the only instance, though. Yes, yes. But I think we live in an un-Alexandrian age. Right. People are hostile to the ideal of greatness that he embodies.
我的意思是，当时的人并没有说他是个坏人、他是个坏国王。是的，我想他们是这么说的。我是说，我认为在泰尔屠杀的规模……不过那是唯一的例子。是的，是的。但我认为我们生活在一个“去亚历山大化”的时代。没错。人们对他在身上体现的伟大理想持敌意态度。
Yeah. People are suspicious of it. But the number of people who replied to this question, I think, indicates that his charisma still blazes bright. Absolutely, it does. We are fascinated by apex predators. We're more interested in, tend to be more interested in Siberian tigers or sharks
是的。人们对此心存怀疑。但回答这个问题的听众数量，我认为表明他的个人魅力依然光芒万丈。绝对是的。我们对顶级掠食者着迷。我们更有兴趣……往往对西伯利亚虎或鲨鱼更感兴趣，
than we are in sheep. Yeah, I'm sure that's true. And I think that Alexander kind of satisfies that need. On which, no, we should end with... I know how I want to end, Tom. No, I want to end with Barry Grogan. Well, you can end with Barry. Is that the last question?
而不是对绵羊感兴趣。是的，我确信是这样的。我认为亚历山大某种程度上满足了这种需求。说到这里，不，我们应该以……我知道我想以什么来结束，汤姆。不，我想以巴里·格罗根（Barry Grogan）来结束。好吧，你可以用巴里来结束。那是最后一个问题吗？
So Barry Grogan has said, I'm 31. Can I conquer a similar sized empire by my next birthday? I think there's tons of time, Barry. I don't, never give up hope. Just don't invade Afghanistan. No, well, I mean, you need an oracle. Maybe Egypt, maybe Egypt. Well, maybe if I read the final lines
所以巴里·格罗根说：我31岁了。我能在下一个生日之前征服一个同样大小的帝国吗？我认为时间还充裕得很，巴里。我不会……永远不要放弃希望。只是别去入侵阿富汗。好吧，我的意思是，你需要一个神谕。也许是埃及，也许是埃及。好吧，也许如果我宣读最后几行
of my children's history of Alexander the Great, then I think that will inspire Barry because this answers his question. So I say, it's great that I'm able to quote myself at the end of the podcast. Yes, yes, Alexander style modesty. So here we go. Historians argue about him to this
我的儿童版《亚历山大大帝》历史书，那么我认为那将会激励巴里，因为这回答了他的问题。所以我要说，很高兴我能在播客结束时引用我自己的话。是的，是的，亚历山大式的谦逊。所以我们开始吧。历史学家们至今仍在为他争论不休，
day some see him as a noble champion of universal brotherhood others as a selfish monster who cared only for fighting and killing how should we remember him screaming defiance on the field of gauga mila slashing decisively through the gordian knot bowing his head before the oracle of amon or sulking in his tent in the rains of India. All these images are true enough, but Tom Holland, perhaps we should remember him as he began as a boy who loved tales of gods and heroes and told his friends that he too will be remembered in poems and songs.
有些人视他为全人类兄弟情谊的高贵捍卫者，另一些人则视其为只关心战斗和杀戮的自私怪物。我们该如何铭记他？是在高加米拉战场上发出不屈的呐喊，是果断斩断戈耳迪之结，是在阿蒙神神谕前顶礼膜拜，还是在印度的连阴雨中窝在帐篷里生闷气。所有这些形象都足够真实，但是，汤姆·霍兰，也许我们应该记住他最初的样子——一个热爱神话和英雄故事的男孩，并告诉他的朋友们，他自己也将被铭记在诗歌和歌谣中。
Now in this, at least, and this is a message to Barry, he was not so different from boys and girls everywhere. Did you write that? Yeah, I'm still going. You literally wrote that.
至少在这一点上——这是给巴里的一个信息——他与其他地方的男孩女孩并没有什么不同。那是你写的吗？是的，我还没说完呢。你竟然真的是自己写的。
Few of us seriously think we are the children of Zeus. Few of us. But we all love stories, and we all love to picture ourselves as the heroes of our own adventures. And perhaps, inside all of us there is an inner alexander this is a terrifying glimpse into the sandbrook soul is this perhaps this is
我们当中很少有人真的认为自己是宙斯的后代。极少有人。但我们都热爱故事，我们都喜欢把自己想象成自己冒险故事中的英雄。或许，在我们所有人的内心深处，都住着一个亚历山大……这简直是对桑德布鲁克灵魂的可怕一瞥，也许这就是
what i tell my son every day perhaps inside all of us there is an inner alexander lifting his eyes to the horizon and dreaming of glory in the world beyond. Well, that's the way to end, isn't it? I didn't expect that reaction, I have to say, but I'll take it. No, it's brilliant. I haven't yet had the chance to read it, but I can't wait. Clearly, you could do with a laugh. I think that that may serve to change the entire attitude to Alexander.
我每天对儿子说的话，也许我们每个人的内心深处都住着一个亚历山大，将目光投向地平线，梦想着在广阔世界中创造辉煌。好吧，这才是结尾的正确打开方式，不是吗？我必须说，我没想到会有这种反应，但我接受了。不，这太棒了。我还没机会读它，但我已经迫不及待了。显然，你需要一场大笑。我认为这或许有助于彻底改变人们对亚历山大的态度。
I think an entire generation may grow up dreaming of becoming Alexander in a way that they used to back in the good old days of Mary Reynolds. Bad news for the people of Iran. Well, no, maybe good news because they can be integrated into a universal brotherhood of man. I look forward to it. So on that happy note, we will see you in a few days for remembrance day a much more solemn occasion but we've actually secretly recorded that one first and i'm sure and you've written a book on that as well haven't you on the first
我想整整一代人可能会梦想成为亚历山大，就像他们过去在玛丽·雷诺兹的美好旧时光里一样。这对伊朗人民来说是个坏消息。好吧，也许是好消息，因为他们可以融入全人类的普遍兄弟情谊中。我对此非常期待。带着这个快乐的音符，我们将在几天后与大家见面，共同迎来阵亡将士纪念日，这是一个庄严得多的场合，但实际上我们已经秘密先录制了那一集，而且我确信你也写过一本关于那本书的书，对吧，关于第一次
world war yeah oddly it's funny how these things happen isn't it it's weird how they keep popping up uh do you have any inspirational messages for boys and girls in that book yeah there's a boy and girl inside out all of us tom beneath the layers of cynicism i know uh i know the listeners think of me as a much less cynical person than you clearly and a lovable uncle yeah well there are different kinds of uncles, aren't there? A lovable one. Encouraging boys and girls to invade Persia. Right.
世界大战，是的，奇怪的是，这些事情发生的方式真是有趣，不是吗？它们不断涌现，这真是太奇怪了。那本书里有什么给男孩女孩的励志信息吗，汤姆？是的，在我们所有人的内心深处都有一个男孩和一个女孩，汤姆，在重重玩世不恭的外表之下，我知道，我知道听众觉得我是一个比你明显没那么愤世嫉俗的人，是一个慈祥的叔叔。是的，好吧，叔叔有不同的类型，不是吗？一个讨人喜欢的。鼓励男孩和女孩入侵波斯。好吧。
On that note, see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就这样，我们下次再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。如需收听奖励剧集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。